[Applause]
veteran columnist for The New York Times
please cook them very wise berry are you
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so glad you're here I've been
wanting to have on more people to talk
about this issue in a very open-minded
way and you seem very open-minded I am
very good I'm very concerned about a
widening gap between how all of us speak
about the me2 movement privately or
anything really in America these days
you know in our own homes among our
friends and then how we do it in public
and of course with social media
everybody has a sort of public persona
yes and we're becoming ourselves and our
avatar yeah and I like people who keep
it real and I think it really have so
first of all address the interesting
part of it which is that the fight is
really between factions of women it's
not between men and women arguing right
so obviously the me2 movement is long
overdue as we've seen today with Rob
Porter and everyone else but there's a
real debate happening between the hard
left and liberals the hard left is
basically saying it's okay if a few
innocent men go down with the ship if
that's what it means if that's what it
takes to bring down the patriarchy they
hate zero tolerance on the right when it
comes to drug policy but they love zero
tolerance when it comes to sexual
misconduct that's a problem because what
it does is collapse all the categories
it means that Aziz Ansari is on a list
next to Harvey Weinstein and I don't
think anyone with common sense thinks
that that's reasonable
right
[Applause]
the Liberals and we can't I think you
and I count ourselves among them right
we want to see a change in society we
believe this is overdue correct there
are those same goals but I think
personally that the way to get there and
the way to make this a mainstream
sustainable movement is to stick to
things I don't know like due process
like it is until proven guilty yes I
don't think a politics that basically
says this category of person men is
toxic and tainted is a good kind of
politics we see where that ends up and
what about men just shut up because well
everybody knows 10 but any many nobody
no men spoke at the Golden Globe right
you know meant meant and when a man does
say the wrong thing and Matt Damon by
the way did not say the wrong thing
exactly and then he said after he said
what he said which is righteousness
apologizing said I should just shut up
this is what I'm asking this is not
going to help because you know he after
he said what he said he added but both
those things he was I meant rape and a
pat on the butt he's worse than the
other but he said both should be
eradicated never condoned yes and you
know when you're wrong even when you say
the right thing this is what then I feel
like a husband if you understand why
people are silencing themselves why are
people silencing themselves on this
issue they see what happens when they
say the right thing it's wrong exactly
and that's that's a terrifying prospect
and that is what's happening I mean
there's sort of trial by Twitter not
only for the people that are accused
right not only for the people who once
they're accused by the way how do you
what office do you go to to regain your
reputation but it's also if you step out
of line even slightly with the hard left
feminist orthodoxy all of a sudden like
me you're a traitor to your gender
you're an anti-feminist you're condoning
rape culture is also your generation
though there is also a war within the
generations and I think within your
generation and you have to win it I'm
trying you must
I am Telling You 25% of millennial aged
men right asking someone for a drink
constitutes sexual harassment well if
that sexual harassment is doing this is
sexual assault and unsolicited kisses
rape
we've lost it's over right that's game
over then words don't mean anything
what's important is that that's true any
fiber and this is what I always try to
keep in mind when I'm feuding with the
Millennials I don't think it's the
majority of them I think it's the upper
middle class kids who grew up screaming
at their parents and though and that was
okay and it's been and they are just so
[ __ ] fragile excuse me they're like I
think of them as emotional hemophiliacs
and the rest of us have have to be so
careful
[Laughter]
take my penis out well this is what's
happening I had someone touched me on
the elbow the other day and they like
froze and apologized I had someone else
email me and say I'm so sorry I said
what are you sorry for we were on a
podcast together he was apologizing
because he told me that I sounded like
he usually used the word cute was like
you sounded really cute and smart and it
was I was like you're losing your head
people are losing their minds they are
losing their minds and they're gonna
bleed what is so great out of life I
mean we're valent this is the first b2
Valentine's to take over you know I mean
who knows what to write in the car
you know you can't make anything 100%
safe a police state they always say is
the safest place to live right but
you're in a police state correct okay we
don't want to do that with love we've
spent our whole history as humans saying
it's magical it's serendipity a lot of
it happens subconsciously we don't know
why we're attracted to somebody or why
it works or what somebody turns us on
you can't legislate all this or rule it
out of existence right I do think
however that there's an opening in this
moment one thing I think is true is that
I was put through that system that you
talked about the snowflake Factory
you know I went to a college where I was
told that gender is a social construct
nature doesn't matter at all that
there's really no difference between men
and women I'm sorry that's just those
are myths okay and that's lie that the
sexual revolution sold to women and I
think one exciting thing about this
moment is that there's an opening for to
revisit the sexual revolution and the
fact that all of our sexual conversation
you know the conversation about our
sexual culture is about consent and pain
whatever happened to intimacy and love
and romance that's become a dirty word
but it no short name I want to be
courted but that doesn't mean sex but no
but courted means may be pursued which
means maybe who maybe somebody got the
wrong idea no person you didn't you once
but it's but to me there's a tremendous
contradiction between that and then
tinder like why well like you know if
you if you asked me for a drink at a
sexual-harassment and if I do that to
you at work that is sexual harassment
but
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
right your generation a little [ __ ]
crazy